turning overseas the immense human
tragedy of the earthquakes in turkey and
Syria is being made even worse in some
areas by lack of Aid that's especially
true in Syria where many victims were
refugees from the country's Civil War
MTS Tire crossed the border into Rebel
Hill territory in the northern part of
the country where he found heartbreak
and determination
at just five years old little Janan is
afraid and in pain doctors say her leg
will need to be amputated
she became a symbol of the earthquake's
cruelty when this video of her trapped
under the rubble in Rebel held idlib
along with her baby brother Abdullah
went viral
can be heard pleading with her rescuer
saying please get me out of here
nine-month-old Abdullah is being treated
in the bed next to her while they both
may have survived the Quake their mom
dad brothers and sisters all died
um abdullah's their aunt how are you
feeling with this terrible situation
my heart is burning she says
idlibs huddham City Hospital is
straining under the weight of so much
pain and need
do you have what you need or do you feel
forgotten by the world
the world has definitely forgotten us he
says we haven't received Aid in a very
long time across the rebel-held
territory buildings have collapsed in
their hundreds the need here is so great
but so little Aid has come here to
Northern Syria and people are desperate
a desperation that is Tangled Up in the
fault lines of Syria's decade-long Civil
War
president Bashar al-assad wants control
of all supply routes and world leaders
don't want to legitimize the regime
they've sanctioned a complex situation
that stands in the way of helping this
seriously injured like little Bayonne
who's being visited by her cousin nice
to meet you too her older sister Fatima
lies in a bed next to her with an
injured leg their aunt um Hassan tells
us their mother died in the Quake
we haven't told them about their mother
yet she says I don't have the heart to
tell them she's dead
now the U.N says two and a half million
Syrian children have been affected by
the quake and they are in desperate need
of the basics things like adequate
shelter and drinking water so little of
which is available and so many questions
as to when or if they might get it Tony
oh wow just really tough story there MTS
thank you very much for your reporting I
know sam power told us yesterday with
usaid what they most need is money not
materials at this point